le carburant coule à flot cela faisait
une semaine que cette station attendait
un ravitaillement total et victime de
son succès avec son rabais de 20
centimes sur les prix mais pas seulement
15% des stations services en France
toutes marques confondues manque d'un ou
plusieurs carburants la faute à une
grève dans plusieurs raffineries sur
l'ensemble du territoire elle devrait
perdurer tant que les revendications des
salariés ne sont pas entendus
cette chasse anti-oiture en France
depuis des années
et disproportionnée me semble-t-il mais
surtout les constructeurs vont plus
pouvoir construire des voitures
thermiques en France très rapidement ce
qui fait qu'on va aller acheter des
voitures thermiques en Chine c'est je
veux dire tout ça et comme toujours avec
l'État c'est n'importe quoi votre permis
en plus il est valide donc
sous ces cases que des youtubeurs ils
sont 22 à prendre le départ sur le
légendaire circuit du Mans après tout le
monde tout le monde doit regarder cette
course une course insolite le Grand Prix
explorer organisé par le fameux youtuber
Squeezie c'est hyper émouvant c'est
extraordinaire là il y a 40000 personnes
qui se déplacent ici pour nous voir il y
a plein de gens qui découvrent le sport
auto aussi avec cet événement c'est un
peu une consécration pour pour tout le
monde quoi si vous ne croyez pas où
dérèglement climatique dites-le parce
que vraiment on sait pas de quoi on
parle pourquoi on fait ça c'est pas par
idéologie c'est parce qu'on a constaté
constaté
scientifiquement qu'il fallait réduire
les émissions de gaz carbonique donc à
partir de là il faut prendre et c'est
nous qui nous punissons alors que le
monde entier s'en fiche c'est nous mais
français dans tous les domaines nous
devons se punir de ça vous tromper
encore une fois voilà
je saute dans le fleuve bidon d'essence
pour rien la voiture la carte
il enchaîne les provocations devant des
gendarmes impassibles qui en ont vu
d'autres l'événement est aussi
spectaculaire derrière les écrans
une régie professionnelle ayant déjà
couvert des Grands Prix de Formule 1
film la course retransmisant direct sur
la plateforme twitch le record de twitch
a été
bat un record d'audience en France plus
d'un million de spectateurs témoins de
la victoire de Sylvain Nelly au terme
des 15 tours
[Musique]
si vous pensez vraiment que les
émissions de CO2 sont responsables du
changement climatique c'est ce que tous
les scientifiques disent en tout cas bon
si vous pensez le contraire il faut être
contre tous
je dis que tout ça ne sera rien mais je
vous laisse la responsabilité de votre
incroyable en matière de la chanson
climatique vous êtes prêt à la maison on
va passer la soirée tous ensemble
jusqu'à présent Danse avec les stars on
était thermostat 4 ce soir on met
thermostats 22
je baisse
[Musique]
je décale
cet hiver pour vous réchauffer
[Musique]
pensez au parcours c'est vrai que c'est
70 elle ressemble un petit peu aux
années 2020 c'est à dire c'est quand
même des années on l'a oublié où il y
avait beaucoup de guerres beaucoup
d'instabilité politique géopolitique il
y avait la guerre du Vietnam qui se
termine il y avait un grand chaos quand
même dans le monde entier il va encore
les deux blocs URSS contre États-Unis
etc elle peut à l'image de ce qui se
passe à notre époque un carton il fait
bon vivre qu'est-ce que tu appelles pour
toi un quartier où il fait bon vivre
[Musique]
par terre après avec le vent ça les
poissons
[Musique]
d'apocalypse nucléaire le président
américain estime que Vladimir Poutine ne
plaisante pas quand il brandit la menace
nucléaire selon lui le président russe
ne veut ni perdre la ni perdre le
pouvoir il est en effet acculé en raison
des nombreux revers militaires je sais
effectivement que votre temps est compté
le notre aussi n'est peut-être un
désormais si j'ai bien écouté monsieur
cette nuit puisque elle est peut-être
que tous ces sujets là
n'existeront plus dans quelques semaines
que la police calypses
sera arrivé et que nous serons ailleurs
il y avait une insouciance considérable
notamment au point de vue écologique on
avait commencé méthodiquement à détruire
la planète mais dans la méconnaissance
absolue du mal qu'on faisait avec voilà
tous les polluants qui commencent les
insecticides tous ces trucs là et puis
une grande confiance en l'avenir c'était
une époque où on était persuadé que
demain serait mieux c'est plus tout à
fait le cas aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est un film assez consensuel et qui
fait du bien il donne envie de s'aimer à
la fin tu as envie de dire tu as envie
de dire à tes parents que tu les aimes
et j'espère
vice Versailles bah c'est génial
quelle belle parole pour finir cet
entretien